meanwhile we are barely four weeks
before the midterm elections and many of
the key races could not be closer let's
show you the latest CBS News you gov
Battleground tracker it shows the race
to control the Senate is at this moment
in time essentially a toss-up CBS News
elections and surveys director Anthony
salvato is here Anthony good morning
there are basically five key races that
are going to determine control of the
Senate we're going to focus on one of
them Wisconsin what do we know that is
correct and this could not be closer
incumbent Ron Johnson the Republican 50
to 49 against Mandela Barnes the
Challenger polling terms that's
effectively tied right but the reason it
is is some of these Universal themes
we're seeing throughout all these states
Tony and I want to start with the
economy on economic policies Ron Johnson
is leading it's the number one reason
people say they're voting for him that's
true of Republicans across a lot of
these states right people concerned
about the economy about inflation but
it's abortion that is helping the
Democrats that's the top reason people
say they're voting for Barnes It's
motivating Democrats it's motivating
women I I would add that Republicans
want to add another issue to all of this
and that is crime the running attack ads
against Democrats against Barnes calling
them saying they want to defund the
police well look at this Johnson has an
edge on this key metric of whose
policies would keep you safe from crime
that's holding down Barnes numbers a
little bit but Democrats counter they
want to make this about democracy want
to make the point that they say Ron
Johnson tried to overturn the election
results and when The Independents think
he did they're less likely to vote for
him so the effort by Republicans to
paint Democrats as soft on crime and
wanting to defund the police it looks
like it's working to some extent at
least in Wisconsin it is working to some
extent it is unpopular as a in principle
voters don't want less funding for the
police so that's a line that Republicans
are using it is being somewhat effective
here but I would add Again part of this
is what is this election about and
Democrats want to add that democracy
part of it because that has an effect
especially among Independents against
Republicans democracy an abortion on the
Democrat side uh democracy and uh
Republicans want this to be about the
economy and about crime
and those two issues are working for
them very good lost it for a second but
I think I found it again Anthony zamato
thank you very much